fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
la tempête a aussi soufflé avec force
sur le château de versailles
durant deux heures au petit matin avec
les moyens du bord
on essaie ici de recenser les dégâts
échafaudage démonter toitures abîmées
vitres brisées il n'y a pas de dégâts
dans les salles pour l'instant
simplement il ya des liens d y ait des
trous un peu partout dans les toitures
silac lui arrive a reconduit le sens de
bâches et de fermes urnes aura des
dégâts mais ça on sait surtout que le
parc a souffert plus encore qu'en 90
lorsque la tempête emporté sur son
passage près de deux milliers d'arbres
selon les premières estimations le vent
aurait balayé aujourd'hui quelques 4000
arbres des arbres aux anciens qui
avaient été pour la plupart planté au
siècle dernier
cent ans d'histoire pour finir comme ça
un petit matin